[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
はいえーとご紹介にあずかりました8名在学の理工学部建築学科で
と今所助教ですね押しております泉山と申します
市はですね4月になったらほかの大学に行ってしまうので今年がここに出れるのが最後
だなと思って
あのまいりました宜しくお願いします
越冬
今日はですね外を楽しむアイディアとサードプレイスという風なテーマでお話しさせて
いただきたいと思います
外は皆さんあのよく使うと思うんですが
サードプレイスについてはご存じのかたてあげていただけますでしょうか
あまり知らないです
えっとサードプレートはですねえっとファーストプレイスっていうのは自宅と言われて
います自分の家
セカンドプレイスが仕事場だとか学校のばみんな多くはここを吹くしています
でそれ以外の場所が番サードプレイスなんですけれども
例えばスターバックスのカフェで仕事をしたりとか
他いろんな場所があると思うんですけれどもそういったものをサードプレイスとしてい
ます
最近はですねカフェで仕事をするっていうのがちょっと前までご謝礼だったりとか皆
こうそれに憧れてたというとこもあったと思うんですけどだんだんみんなそれをやり
だして大衆化してきていて
山となくですねちょっと外に
それを求めてきているとそういうふうなところがあります
まあ再生なところもありますのでえーす今日は外についてちょっとお話したいと思い
ます
えっと私はあの先のメジャー役のほかにもでね外の場というウェブマガジンの編集長し
てたりとか
一般社団をやってたりしておりますけれども
これおくとか将来日本がこういう風になったらいいなというふうなものの絵を
深く引いたとよりも書いてもらいました
いろんな a アイディアが
詰まっています例えば
そうですね水辺で川の底でビアガーデンをしたりとかあるいは
真ん中にありますけれども広場で海外だとチェスを
大きい実物大の欠損を作っ使っていたりとかですね
そういういろんなアイディアが海外にはたくさんあるしそれが
海外で行われているというふうに思います
でそれを僕は日本でもうちょっと増えたらいいなというふうに思っています
粗糖なんですけれども a
難しくてかちょっと漢字で書けば屋外ですね
屋外空間と言いますでえっと屋外空間って
そうですね皆さん何気なく普段使っているかと思うんですけれども
まぁなんとなくパブリックスペースというかちょっと公共のものみたいな
感覚があるかなと思います
では皆さんそういった外ってどういう風にしクビになってるんだろうとか
どういう風になったら使えるんだろうということが多分あまり
また学校で習ったこともないと思いますし
知らないと思うんですね私はそういうふうなことを研究してたりと軽いは握手をしてい
たりするのでちょっとそこのヒントをご紹介したいと思います
8外を楽しくするコツっていうのは身近な
外まで自分で楽しむことだと思います
誰かがこうイベントをしてそれにたいステップを利用するっていうのもあると思うん
ですけれども
でも外を楽しいも秘訣みたいなことを自分が知らないと全っっっ
その圧倒的に好町額を楽しくなっていたないというふうに思いますね
で皆さんの
身近な外っていうのはどこでしょうかっていうことを
いきたいと思っていました
まあ自分のいう玄関でたら道路があったりとか
あるいは近くの公園とかあるいはそうですね職場の
オープンスペースとかいろいろあると思うんですけれども
で実はそこ
の写真なんですけれども
まあ僕はまあメジャーが降ったのでちょっといろいろ研究とか知った時に
ここってなんでいつも静かな空間なんだろうなということをちょっと調べたことがある
んですね
で多分ここでメディアの学生の人はここで何かをしているということを
たぶん見たことないんじゃないかなと思いますたぶんほとんど何も敷けないと思います
明治大学は眉今読んキャンパスあっては僕は生田と中野に行ったり来たりしてるですが
生田割とちょっととシエンタよりも山方にあるので最近はこういった芝があってですね
天気の良い時は昼間で昼ごはんを食べしたりします
そういうときは結構空いたそっと楽しいの
だと思うんですけど他はですね泉とか数が台とか中のは割と星にあるということもあり
ましてあまり
阿部ないってこととかちょっと高額性が高
いろいろやるとちょっとすぐあのいろいろ問題が起きそうなこともあったりするので
すごい管理が厳しい
えっとこういったところで例えば音楽をしたい学生がエイジスをしたりとか何か後学生
がダンスをしたりというふうなことが pot あったら楽しいなと思うんですけれど
も実は今あんまり行われてないかなと思います
えっと僕実は今週アメリカに行ってたんですがみんな海外旅行から日本に帰ってくると
口をそろえて言うのはですね
右側のプライベート民間の敷地のまあ例えばこの双子魂辛いですけども
の再開発とかをされたようなスペースというのはすごい
お金もかかっていてきれいで立派だなと思います
なんだけれども public ですね道路や公園ヘとか
商店街とかそういうふうなスペースというのはなんとなくこう
チープだなぁと思いますでもアメリカヨーロッパっていうのはパブリックがスペースも
なんとなくニギニギし買ったりとかちょっと綺麗だったりします
そういうふうなさっていうのが少し日本の今の課題なんじゃないかなと思っています
日本の都市僕は都市計画を専門にしているんですけれども
日本は基本的には民間の普通の不動産ですねと公共の不動産っていうの2つがあるん
じゃないかなと思ってまして
このパブリックな不動産の部分が今いろんな動きがあるという風な状況です
でえっと難しいことはあまり言いませんけれども
いろんな法律で縛られています後期を食うか例えばですね公園とか道路河川
頭考案ですね皆とっていうのもありますし
そうですねまぁ公開空地っていうのはそこにあるような民間のスペースだったりとか
あとは先の二子玉みたいな商業接続あるようなところすです
また駅前広場もありますしあとは口とか駐車場もそれも全部
外ですって
レーマーこういった層とっていうのは様々な法律とか制度で縛られています
なんだけれどもまああとその行政が持ってたりあるいは民間の人が持つデルっていう
ふうにご所有も分かれています
でも外っていうのは
なんかこう誰かなものになっているような感じが今してるんですね
そこに僕はまぁ本来であればパブリックスペースっていうのはみんなのものじゃなかっ
たのかなと
いうふうに思っていてだんだんだんだんですね
街がどんどん窮屈社会が窮屈になってきていてそれで
なんかこうなんでも出来た社会だったのがなんかだんだん何もできなくなってきたん
じゃないから
今はですね例えば
そうですねビアガーデンあるいは道路べっ甲歩行者天国にしたイベントとかする
全部強化が必要です道路であれば自治体というのは行政ですね市役所と各役所
ここでは千代田区役所に行かなきゃいけ
行った道路は警察にも教会なきゃいけ
公演も河川を受けませ
あとは基地空地ですねまぁそこもそうですけどそこの場合であれば大学人許可を得なっ
た理由
強化だらけです誤解がこういうのはいいかに突破シーンをかけてあることをやってます
けど
でまぁみんなこれよくあるのは公園とか
いろんなスパブリックスペースはこの強化を得なきゃいけないっていうところになって
くるともうあらかじめ禁止事項
これはやっちゃいけないみたいなことをどんどん書き始めました
禁煙火気厳禁とかまぁ危険別も仕込みぐらいは分かるんですけれども
撮影しちゃダメですよとか物品ダメですよとかですね
どんどんののルールが増えていきます
でへ
なんかゼッケンちゃぴよ所ダメとかですねガー
はい細いの実もがあるんですけども
そうですねだんだんですねネット坂になって
クリームが増えてきたんですねそれが結局
ルールが増えてくるというようなことになっていては山な過剰なれる社会にもなってき
ている
それ以外がパブリックスペースを窮屈にしているんだなと思います
でもですねさっきのような禁止事項
とでしょ
同じにを見るとなんか公園に方がこれが張った句としたら何をしていいのかが分から
ないですよね
なので
そうなってくるとなんか
何かやっちゃいけないのかなみたいなことだんだん数心理になってその結果ですには
パブリックスペースとか外がもう使われてないという風になってるんじゃないのかな
その緊張北楽器を解き解くしたいと思います
でまぁさっきのようなこんな感じですけども
まあプレイヤーとかアクティビストっていきますけどまぁこういうふうに外何か使う人
にしてピクニックでも何でもいいのお花見ても何度もいい
そういったことをまずはアイディアをやってみればいいというふうに思っています
でなんですけどちょっとし強化とかもう必要な時もあるので
まあ例では理解してねっていうふうなことはよく行ってます
ちょっと堅い話をすればパラダイム4ストですね
社会が変わってきています人口増加はもうだんだん人口減少しているしクルマ社会から
旦那1 a の社会になっ
だんだんガンガンガンガン講師のして空間をつくってきたり建物を作っていたのが今
工場を運営していこうというかですね凍りつきの重視から
豊かさを求め
経済とかお金っていうふうなことだけではなくてば環境とか良い事かです
どんなやっぱ社会時代が変わってきているっていうとこがあります
今の町あるいは外っていうのはこの左側の方で
中心に考えて作られて来ていいのですごい窮屈なんですね
で8外がだんだん
人のためになってきていると皆さんが来使いやすくなってきているというふうに思って
います
そこでアメリカの話をアメリカの2つの話をしたいと思います
これはですねタイムズスクエアですね水実前に行ってきました
カウントダウン年末のカウントダウンときなこパーッと人があり増えるんですけれども
これは2008年ぐらいまでの風景です
そうですね両側に歩道があって人がたくさん rete
真ん中にも人が歩いていってあとは自動車がを笑ってこう言うと
まあん
そうですねこの道路空間というのは誰のためなんだろうっていう風に
おったら車の日目ですね車社会アメリカです
ですが今は
この前行ってみたらこんな風景になってました
車ちょっとあるんですけれども圧倒的に
広場になってました
まあ行ってみてですね結構椅子テーブルが右がねあったりとかしますけれども
へ
まぁそこを座って何か食べたりとかちょっと子ゆっくりしたりとか
こんなまぁちょっと周り広告技術月なんですけども
なんかこう居心地が入って言えな場所でした
で実際にこれはですねなんで急に変わったのってお話をするんですが
実験をちょっとしたんですね
この右側道路をペイントしてテーブル椅子を出して
外を使ったらどういう風になるのかっていうな実験をしました
でヨーロッパとオープンカフェって昔からあるんですけど
アメリカってまだそんなに無かったん
で
アメリカ人はこういったそうなんですね
僕たちはアメリカ人だからヨーロッパでの人と同じように座らないよ
入ったみたいです
でなんですけどやってみたら座っているんですね
やっぱり人ってまぁさっき再度ペースと言いましたけど居心地のいい場所っていう風な
ものがあれば
ますことでどんどん座ったりとかくつろいだりし始めです
これはちょっとタイムすけある道路の形をしたような家具みたいな感じですけどすごい
この至近距離で他人がいろいろ
スは同じ furniture で座っていてなかなかないなと
で8これ実験の時の風景ですけどもうご飯を食べたりとかなんか本読んでたりとか
いろんな人がこうくつろいでいるまあそういうふうな風景が
a
さっきの切れ間社会でも生まれました
でこれが何しているかと言うヨガですね
他の実験の時だと思いますけれどもこんな車がバンバンバンバン走って人が歩いている
中で
ヨガをしている
こんな感じですね
まああの
なんかその辺なんですけれどもまぁでもそのなんか
人のための場所になってるなっていうような感じがしますし
なかなか口を非日常というかなかなか体験できないから子様みんな包んだと思うんです
ね
やっぱ外っていうか気持ちいいんですねだから
まあヨガクラスみたいところに行くよりも外で行ったほうが健康的だなと思うから
みんな道路の真ん中でそんなインパクトがあるかなと
これはですねあのさっきの車って載ってる人って結局一人なんですよねそういうふうに
は自転車もいますけども
さっきの乗っている人集ちゃうとこれぐらいのスペースしかないですよねというような
話です
つまり道路はフィルマーのためにやっているよりも歩行者のために行ったほうが圧倒
的に
市民のため人のためになるじゃないかというようなことがまあ調査結果から示されて
さっきのが見つければ変わったと
いるなとこですこの場所タイムスクエアではないですけども考え方としては同じかなと
思います
22対8の法則みたいな感じで8割きゅるまだったのが8割が1になったと
いう事例でした
次もう一つパークレッドのお話をしたいと思います
a
パークレッドってなかなか聞いたことないと思いますがこれサンフランシスコですねに
視界が
にこういう風な風景がありました
アメリカ車社会なので路上パーキングが多いですなので
もうどんどん車がたくさんあるんです
そこ猫悪いているとポコッと何かこう
ウッドデッキみたいなスペースがで底部にスバルみたいとこれはパークレットです
これが8アメリカに先週行った時に
30サッコさん公民テーマはりました
でこれなんで生まれたかというとこういったパーキングスペースにですね高芝を張って
ですね
公園のように使ってみようっていう風な蹴りが的な動きから始まったんですね
でこういう風になって a どんどんこれいいねっていう風投げリーダーアクションが
そうですね
どんどん政策になって制度になってくる
でなっていきましたまあ財布に生まれました
でまぁ日本でも外では日本の外の話をするとどんどん人のために使われ始めてきてい
ます
そのイベントを紹介したいと思いますけれどもこれ入力肛門にあのコミュんですね
これ2010円できてキッチンカーとかね度かでどんどん版を作っていくっていうのが
生まれましたし
い下北沢刑事これも昨年できました
池袋これ私プロデュースしたんですけど道路でオープンカフェしたりとかマーケットし
たりみたいな話とか
千葉にも空き地がいろいろ使われている
横浜の公演をどんどん開放していこうとかですね
これは愛知県の岡崎なんですけどかわぁを使っていこうみたいな話を追ってます
えっ取ったもしかないんですけどもそのいろんなものを紹介して子っていう a
magazine お外の歯っていうのをやっていますこの外のば.プレイスっていう
風な検索していただくと出てくる web マガジンです
まあさっき言ったように彼以外の愛でお知らないってことと日本の事例はベジェぶりに
乗ってないねってことからもっとどんどんどんどん
web がに情報が来れば
どんどんみんなしれるじゃないかというようなことから行ってきました
でまぁこういうてな場を作ったりとかやってます
あとはですねアクションをしていてこれは
晴れのうちの中通りいうスペースでセダンは真ん中にいっていうかと仮定病だって
けれども
卓球台を
絡みのシーンか誰も乗っています
冬はやっぱりあのテーブル椅子だけだと極左の意味ここで八経済をし
で卓球したらもっと暖かくなりねってことで
こういう風な外へのアクションっていう風なものもこれから必要だと思う2
東急なものがあったらもっとことが楽しくなるんじゃないかなぁと思います
で僕はですね夫たち結婚したんですけれども結婚式お外でやりました
やはりえっと自分自身が外を楽しまなきゃいけないじゃないと人が外で楽しむという
ことが行われないと思います
まあこれは長さ1な風景なんですけれども
やっぱり外って一人だけ気使うと結構寂しいですよね
でも2人3人てこういろいろやっていくとどんどんどんどん人がなんか
コミュニケーションバレたりとか
なんかここがいていいんだなというふうに思えるバーになってくるので
まあそういうふうなことをしていくってくるとか大事かなと思います
まあへ
時間もないので
皆さんも日本の外をもっと楽しんでいただきたいなというふうに思います以上です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]